CIRELLI LINE FOR TAMPA.
COLBY MENTIONED THEY PLAYED
EIGHT TIMES  TOEWS PICKS OFF AK
POINTS-BLANK.
THE VETERAN COREY PERRY,AGEL!
>> Caley: A SHOT, CAN'T
BELIEVE THAT HE MISSED THAT ON.
POINT HIS WAY AHEAD.
HE WANTS KANE!
OH, HE HAD THE PUCK KNOCKDOWN, E
HAWKS WERE ABLE TO TRANSITION
THE PUCK U BUICK, ALL  FORECHEC
A GREAT BLOCKED SHOT RIGHT
THERE BY THE HAWKS IN
NATIONOFF WINS, AND YOU SAIDBAC
TAYLOR RADDYSH, JUST A NO-LOOK,
AND KIRBY DACH IS ON HIM, BUT
HE'S NOT PLAYING HIM
THAT ALL SEASON.
>> NOW SETH JONES MOVE'S IT
AHEAD.
HE WORLD.
I'VE ALWAYS LOVED WATCHING
AGAIN KURASHEV TO McDONAGH.  TH
AND WHAT A THE HAWKS.
YOU HAVE TWO DIFFERENT PLAYERS
IN IN FRONT FOR THE HAWKS.
NOT A LOT OF TRAFFIC THEIR
PLAYERS PLAY OFFENSE
THATD FIND WAYS TO WIN
GAMES WITHOUT THEIR TOP PLAYERS
IN THE LINE-
PUTTING EVERYTHING THEY HAVE ONE
OFF THE RUSH.
>> Pat:
IT'S ONE OF THOSE APPLIES FOR
ALEX DEBRINCAT, WHERE HE'S IN
THE CORNER, AND FOIT.
QUICK SHOT STAMKOS.
GOOD LOCK OUT FRONT OF THE BY
DE LOOKINGTO THE NET!
OH, COULDN'T QUITE COMPLETE THE